- [Voiceover] So we already know that
chromosomes are made up of
really long strands of DNA
all wound up into themselves,
so something like, well
I'm just kind of drawing it
as a random long strand of
DNA all wound up in itself.
And on that strand,
you have sequences which we call genes,
so that might be one
gene right over there,
this might be another gene,
that might be a gene right over there.
And each of those genes can
code for specific polypeptides
or specific proteins.
And the key question is,
is how do you go from
the information encoded in these genes,
encoded as sequences of DNA,
how do you go from that?
How do you go from the gene,
which is encoded in DNA,
how do you go from that to protein?
Which is made up of polypeptides,
which are made up of amino acids.
And this is often called the
central dogma of biology,
but we already saw in the
video of transcription,
that the first step is to go from the gene
to messenger RNA,
that the RNA, the messenger RNA,
you can use as a transcript,
we have rewritten the
information now as RNA.
And then the next step
which we're gonna dive into
in this video is going from
that message RNA to protein,
and this process is called translation,
because we're literally
translating that information
into a polypeptide sequence.
And you can see a little
bit visually here,
this is all review, we
covered a lot of this
in the video on transcription
and the overview video on
transcription and translation,
is if you look at a eukaryotic cell
and the bacteria in a prokaryotic cell,
it's analogous, you just don't
have the nuclear membrane,
and you're not gonna
do the processing step
that I'm gonna talk about in a little bit
and we went in detail on
the video on transcription.
But you start with the DNA,
you have your RNA
polymerase as the main actor
that's able to transcribe
the RNA from that.
If we're talking about a eukaryotic cell,
what you end up with we wouldn't call mRNA
we would call pre-mRNA,
pre-mRNA,
which then needs to be processed,
the introns need to be taken out,
we add a cap and a tail here,
and if we're talking
about a eukaryotic cell,
we then formally call that mRNA,
and then it can travel,
and this is where we get
into the translation step.
It can travel to a ribosome,
which is where it will be translated
into a polypeptide sequence.
And you see the analogous
thing happening here
in this bacterial,
or this prokaryotic cell right over here,
except you don't see the nuclear membrane,
because it's prokaryotic,
and you don't see that processing step,
so you could just consider this straight,
this is mRNA right over there.
So the questions are well
how does this thing happen?
And what even is a ribosome?
So let's zoom in a little bit
on a ribosome right over here,
and there's a couple
of interesting actors.
One, as you can imagine,
is the ribosome itself,
and it is made up of proteins,
proteins plus ribosomal RNA.
So in the video on transcription,
we're already familiar with messenger RNA
and we often view RNA like DNA
as primarily encoding information,
it's acting as a transcript for a gene,
but it doesn't have to
only encode information.
It can also, so it's proteins plus,
it's not a 'T' there, this is a plus.
It can also provide a
functional structural role,
which it does in ribosomal RNA.
And this big, you know, this looks like a
an oversized hamburger bun
or something right over here,
this is super oversimplification
of what a ribosome looks like
and I encourage you to do a web search
for image searches for ribosomes,
and then you can get
more appreciation of how
how beautiful these structures are,
and how intricate they actually are.
So this is the site,
and you can broadly think of the ribosome
as having this, you know,
this is the top bun,
and the bottom bun.
And it's going to travel along the mRNA
from the five prime end,
to the three prime end, reading it,
and taking that information,
and turning it into a
sequence of amino acids.
So how does that actually happen?
Well, each, each of these three,
every three nucleotides,
every three nucleotides there,
we call that a codon, so that's a codon,
this is, let me do this in a color
that is visible on both white and black.
So these next three
nucleotides is a codon,
this is a codon, this is a codon,
and what's actually the
information is actually encoded
in the nitrogenous bases.
So this first codon right over here,
we see it's AUG, so the
nitrogenous bases are
adenine, uracil and guanine.
And this has, this codon,
it codes for the amino acid
methianine, but this is also,
this is a good one to know,
AUG, let me write it over here.
AUG is know as the start codon.
Start codon.
This is where the ribosome
will initially attach
to start translating that messenger RNA,
and so we, the way this drawing is,
that we are just starting to translate
this messenger RNA.
So how does that actually happen?
How do we get from these
three letter sequences
to specific amino acids?
Well let's think about it, how many,
how many possible three
letter sequences are there?
Well, there are,
there are four possible
nitrogenous bases there,
so there's four possible, so
if you, if you have a codon,
and it has three places,
there's four possible things
that could be in the first place.
There's four possible things
that could be in the second place,
and there's four possible
things that could be
in the third place.
So there are 64 possible permutations.
4 times 4 times 4.
Permutations, so you can
think of it, there's 64
different codons,
different ways of arranging
the A, the U and the G.
And that's good, because
there are many amino acids,
and this is actually overkill,
because there's actually
22 standard amino acids,
22 standard,
amino, amino acids,
and 21 that are typically
found in eukaryotic cells.
So we have more than enough,
more than enough permutations
to cover the different amino acids.
And it's not hard to find tables
that will actually show us
what the different sequences,
what they actually code for.
So you can see here, you
can take the first letter,
the second letter and the third letter,
figure, look at the different sequences,
and you can say, okay, look at that.
AUG, adenine, uracil, guanine.
That codes for methanine.
Right over here.
You could do that with any of them,
you could say cytosine, uracil, uracil,
that codes for leucine.
And you can see that it's
not just one amino acid
per codon, but here you have four codons
all code for, all code for leucine.
And so it turns out that 61 of the codons,
let me write this down.
So 61 of the codons, of the possible 64,
code for amino acids,
amino acids,
and three play a role
that essentially tells the
the ribosome to stop, three codons,
three codons are stop codons,
and you can see them right over here.
UAA, UAG, UGA, that's
how the ribosome knows
to stop translating.
So AUG, that's a start codon,
and it codes for methianine.
So that lets you know that
these polypeptide chains
are going to start with methianine,
and then these characters
tell it where to stop.
But how do, how does the amino acid
actually get, how do they
all get tied up together
to form this polypeptide?
And how do they get matched up,
how do they actually get matched up
with the appropriate codon?
And that's where we have
another RNA based actor,
and this is tRNA.
So tRNA, the t stands for transfer,
transfer RNA.
There's a bunch of different tRNAs
that each combined to
specific amino acids,
and on parts of those tRNA,
they have what are called anti-codons.
That pair with the appropriate codon.
So this tRNA, and that's
not what it looks like,
I'll show you in a second
what it looks like.
That's a tRNA molecule, tRNA,
at one end of the molecule,
it's binding to the
appropriate amino acid,
methianine, right over here.
And then at the other end of the molecule,
though that's in the middle
of the tRNA actual chain,
you have your anticodon.
And your anticodon matches
up to the appropriate codon.
And so this is how they bump
into each other the right way
and the ribosomes going to facilitate it,
that the AUG is going to be
associated with the methianine.
And if we look at what
tRNA actually looks like,
and this is still just a visualization.
So this is a strand of tRNA,
you get a sense of, okay,
it's a sequence of RNA
right over here,
this it's, I guess you could
say, you could think of it,
it's two dimensional structure.
But then it wraps around itself to form
this fairly complex molecule.
And the anticodon, which is right here,
it's kind of in the
middle of the sequence,
it forms the basis for
this end of the molecule,
that's the part that's
gonna pair with the codon
on the mRNA,
and then at the other end of the molecule,
at the other end of the molecule
is where you actually bind
to the appropriate amino acid.
So I know what you're thinking, alright,
I see that the ribosome,
it knows where to start,
it starts at the start codon.
I see how the appropriate tRNA can bring
the appropriate amino acid,
but how does the chain actually form?
And you can view this in three steps,
and associated with those
three steps are three sites
on the ribosome.
And the three sites, we
call this the A-site,
you're not gonna be able to
see it if I write it in black.
A, or yellow, alright,
let me write it in blue.
So that is the A-site.
This is the P-site,
and this is the E-site.
And I'll talk in a second
why we call them A, P and E.
So the A-site is where
the appropriate tRNA
initially bounds, the tRNA
that's bound to an amino acid.
And so you can see, we're
starting the translation process,
the next thing that's going to happen
is another tRNA, the one
that is, that matches,
that has an anticodon
that matches the UAU,
that's going to bond
over here on the A-site,
and it's bringing the
appropriate amino acid with it,
it's bringing the tyrosine with it.
So why is that called the A-site?
Well A stands for aminoacyl.
An easy way to remember it
it's the tRNA, it's the
place where the tRNA
that's bound to the amino
acid, just one amino acid
is going to bind on the ribosome.
And so once that happens,
once this character comes here,
let me draw that.
Once this character comes right over here,
it's gonna be AUA,
and it's bound to the tyrosine.
Well then you could
have a peptide bond form
between the two amino
acids, and the ribosome,
and the ribosome itself
can move to the right.
So this, this tRNA
will then be in the E-site.
This tRNA will then be in the P-site,
and then the A-site will be
open for another amino acid
carrying tRNA.
So what this, what do the
P and E sites stand for?
Well you can see a little bit
more clearly right over here.
So the P-site is where you
have the polypeptide chain
actually forming, and,
so the P-site is often,
well, one way to remember
it is is that's where
you have the polypeptide
chain, and now you have a new,
you have a new A-site where you can
bring in a new amino acid.
And then the ribosome is going to shift,
once this is bound, the ribosome,
the peptide bond forms,
and then the ribosome can
shift to the right, when the
ribosome shifts to the right,
we're gonna be in this position,
where the thing that was
here, that was in the A-site,
now the polypeptide is attached to it,
it is now going to be in the P-site,
and the thing that was in the P-site
is now going to be in the E-site.
It is now ready to exit,
and that's why it's called the E-site.
Because that's the site
from which you exit.
And so this is going to keep happening
until we get to one of the stop codons.
And when you get to
one of the stop codons,
then the appropriate polypeptide
is going to be released,
and we will have created this thing
that could either be a protein,
or part of a protein, so
this is very exciting,
because this is happening
in your cells as we speak.
This is, and in fact if
you think about things
like antibiotics, the
way that they work are,
is that, or the way that antibiotics work
is that ribosomes and prokaryotes
are different enough than
ribosomes in plants and animals
or in eukaryotes, that
we can find molecules
that hurt the function of
ribosomes in prokaryotes,
but don't do it to eukaryots.
And so if you have bacteria
in your blood stream,
and if you take the
appropriate antibiotic,
it could disrupt this translation process
in the bacteria, but not in your cells
that you want to keep.